developing news that were following from
Las Vegas City Councilwoman Michele
Fiori has stepped down from her role as
mayor pro-tem but there are some who
want her removed from office dozens of
people showed up this morning at City
Hall our Bianca Holman is there now live
with those details hi Bianca afternoon
earlier this morning there was almost a
hundred people gathered here outside of
City Hall in advance of the meeting
starting at 9:00 a.m. and many groups
are represented there were folks from
the n-double-a-cp
- even residents that lived in Ward 6
Michele Fiore's Ward in the northwest
part of the valley recently Fiore has
been under fire for allegedly making
racially charged comments at Clarke
County Republican convention June 6
Ruxandra coy the president of the Las
Vegas N double ACP says biases will not
be tolerated by the black community and
believes the council should stand up for
justice well there was a large crowd
outside City Hall against Fiore's
actions more than 200 people submitted
requests for common in advance of this
meeting when the X had like that
everyone likes to say that the ex-mayor
protip said that she wanted to have a
rally uplifting blue lives matter all
lives matter it was really dismissive of
our experience for those of us who've
been protesting on the streets for the
last few weeks it's dismissive of the
work that the community has been putting
in for years
it's dismissive of our lives in our
history Michele Fiore is not our voice
she's not our voice in Ward 6 she should
not be the voice of her community in Las
Vegas
and that was a Molly Taylor of expel
Michelle she says their focus is to have
the Councilwoman removed from her office
and so since so many comments were
submitted that public comment period has
been moved to later in the meeting and
we'll have an update for you all later
this afternoon